what matters is the facts and the
evidence right and the facts and the
evidence that have been pursued by
however many members of Congress and
their staffs and media looking for any
possible connection has shown time and
time again it doesn't exist if the most
people that are criticizing the Biden
family is is that when the president
calls his son every day and it goes on
the speakerphone he says hello to the
people in the room that is not an
offense that is nothing other than a
loving father okay that's a lovely
father there you've got Abby Lowell
Hunter Biden's attorney already
downplaying the special counsel's probe
as newly appointed as of Friday David
Weiss starts the new job today with a
new week ahead of him a role the
Republican Party warns he cannot be
trusted with well new David David White
same outfit same guy same case Sean
Hannity joins us now to react Sean what
was your reaction great to see you good
morning good morning what was your
reaction on the presser and now that
you've had a chance to talk to so many
people after the change of status
why are we at this place today in your
estimation
well first of all you got to know one
thing about Abby Lowell Abby Lowe is
probably one of the five best attorneys
in the country he's somebody that really
should be taken seriously I have nothing
but great respect for him uh I do
however disagree with him on a lot of
different points here because we've
learned a lot from the house oversight
committee things that we had not known
before the first most obvious charge
that that Weiss Overlook was the issue
of the the the foreign act and you know
the foreign corruption act Provisions
because it's clear that Hunter and his
business partner should have been
registered putting all all of that aside
you've got now the the big question to
me is Joe Biden's involvement here and
everyone keeps saying oh there's no
evidence at all whatsoever that Joe
Biden is involved in any way that's not
true first you have to start at the
beginning why did Joe Biden lie to the
country repeatedly both as a candidate
and as a president when he said over and
over and over again not once did I ever
speak to my son Hunter uh Pete uh Peter
Ducey asked this question numerous times
about his farm business dealing I never
spoke to my brother uh I never spoke to
anybody for that matter why would the
president lie where would the candidate
lie repeatedly about something that now
the house oversight committee has been
has now proven to be false
um and the idea that we have now an
evolution of a lie about a month ago the
White House started answering the
question very differently and they would
say is well as we've been telling you
Joe Biden was never in business with his
son that's not what they were telling us
in the beginning they were telling us
they never spoke about it okay now you
move a little bit further now you got to
ask some serious questions when you look
at the amount of money that we're
talking about with Russia China Ukraine
Kazakhstan and Romania and then you look
at the Shell corporations and the
methods by which they were paying the
Biden family that raises a whole host of
questions and starting with Hunter Biden
who went on Good Morning America and
admitted that he had no experience in
energy oil gas Ukraine I had no
experience in China yet he's doing these
multi-million dollar deals that are
enriching him uh in a field of which he
has no background no experience at all
whatsoever what if the grant what did
Hunter do for that kind of money I'd
like that deal I have no experience put
me on a board I'd love to get paid what
did the grandchildren who also got paid
what did they do for all of that money
and this is where it gets back to Joe
Biden Joe Biden we now know on December
4th 2015 while Hunter was in Dubai with
Barista Executives uh December 4 2015
that's one of those phone calls where
pops was put on speaker and then we have
other messages that Carrabba operate the
Barista Executives were feeling the heat
from that prosecutor his name is Victor
shulkin that was investigating the oil
giant Ukraine barisma and investigating
the president's son from that point on
Joe then begins to make his move which
culminated in him leveraging one billion
taxpayer dollars to get this prosecutor
fired which resulted in his son Hunter
continued he continued to get paid that
was the enrichment of his family that
would be you know a textbook in my view
I'm not an attorney I'll let them weigh
in on it textbook definition of a
bribery allegation that needs to be
investigated now the David Weiss
question your original question which is
very important David Weiss supposedly
had been investigating this for four
years now we're entering year five now
when you listen to the IRS
whistleblowers they were very very clear
what reason would career whistleblowers
have to lie and put their careers and
their pensions on the line those career
whistleblowers okay they said that David
Weiss said to all of them as they were
taking contemporaneous notes that in
fact he did not have jurisdiction over a
hunter Biden in relation to other
investigations like out in Washington DC
and out in California Mary Garland
testified under oath that in fact he did
have that jurisdiction so that's an open
question the bottom line is really
simple why do you pay somebody with no
experience and I'll add one other point
who at the time is an admitted crack
addict millions of dollars uh and for
seemingly
no other reason except for the brand
that Devon Archer talks about and I can
promise you the brand is not Hunter
Biden the brand is Joe Biden vice
president so all all fingers point to
that and all that one other point on the
money uh there's a guy Eric Sherwin who
is part of this company with Devin and
with Hunter and he was sort of like the
money man for this operation and there
are in the in the laptop of Hunter Biden
their emails going back and forth where
he very specifically is being asked by
Hunter how do I pay this bill for Dad
how do I pay for this home repair for
Dad and then of course Hunter famously
complaining half his income goes to Pops
and Tony bobolinski saying oh we got to
put aside 10 for the big guy right so
when you tie it all together and you
start asking the right questions Joe
Biden has a serious bribery money
laundering Scandal uh allegation in
front of him well I tell you Sean you
know obviously this is something the
White House thought this was is going to
go away because a deal was made between
the prosecution and the lawyers but then
about a few weeks ago in front of that
judge up in Delaware the prosecution
said we'll be able to go after him
someday in the future and Hunter Biden's
lawyer said no you can't our whole deal
is he can never be prosecuted because
reportedly they're worried that Donald
Trump or a republican could be elected
and then go after him so if the deal
breaker was as as jelly roll practices
in the background if the deal breaker
was he needed that immunity from future
prosecution it almost sounds as if
Hunter Biden thinks his dad's gonna lose
well it does sound like that in many
ways or they certainly have a fear of
losing how could you not have a fear of
losing I would argue that this Scandal
and Joe Biden having a major fall he's
one step away from the first you know
domino falling over of a prominent
Democrat saying he needs to get out of
this race
um so but let's go back to that point
that you're making Steve because I think
this is critical and that is okay why
didn't the prosecutor Weiss why didn't
he charge him with Fair violations there
we now know both from the whistleblowers
and other reporting that his own office
was recommending felony tax charges on
on Hunter it's it's almost unheard of
that he would go against his own office
on something as significant as that why
the sweetheart deal why the provision
locked into the gun portion of of of the
gun deferment portion of this uh of this
deal why did they sneak in there that he
got to get get out of jail free card for
all time as it relates to any other
criminal activity that he might have
been involved in so you know we're
following this and every detail of it
and I really do have great respect for
Abby I think he's a rock star attorney
if you want a great attorney in
Washington D.C he's right at the top of
the list there are not many great
lawyers there however the evidence now
is becoming overwhelming and I think
Hunter now is he's no longer the real
story here I think the evidence on him
is pretty overwhelming and
incontrovertible and we what we really
need is a special counsel that is
brought in from the outside in that
sense the appointment of Weiss has been
a farce it is a sham and I think it
covers for David Weiss he won't have to
answer the question about the
conflicting stories that he gave to
Congress versus the IRS whistleblowers
Merrick Garland will not be able to be
forced to answer that question either
their answer will be I'd love to comment
but it's an ongoing investigation Sean
what
are you watching that think we're losing
this country there's a two-tier justice
system that Trump has treated
differently than Joe Biden uh that their
family gets a sweetheart deal and Trump
gets possibly a fourth indictment
tomorrow or later this week weaponized
doj what do you say to the people that
are losing faith
uh I say I agree with them you know I
and this saddens me to say it
um you know Mark Levin and one of his
last books wrote you know we're living
in a post-constitutional America these
are really serious times if you don't
have equal justice under the law if you
don't have equal application of our laws
you're basically taken our constitution
the the predicate for all laws in this
country and you're just shredding it and
what's so bad about all of this is we
are criminalizing the justice department
the FBI which we have chronicled that
length where we're weaponizing them
against political opponents uh yeah
we'll probably see in dive in number
four maybe as early as as tomorrow in
out of Fulton County Georgia uh and
meanwhile all of this is pushed under
the rug by the mob in the media this
this will be like the only Network that
exposes Joe Biden's role in all of this
and and really do does a deep dive into
it uh you know David Weiss he's not a
real special counsel looking into this
case has anyone ever heard of this guy
her the one that is supposed to be the
equivalent of Jack Smith Jack Smith is
is doing indictments in Florida
indictments in D.C superseding
indictment indictments in Florida you
know that's not weaponization I don't
know what is yeah realize uh we could
know everything about Jack Smith's case
somehow he ends up in the New York Times
The Washington Post Robert Herr we don't
know where he is uh so uh fascinating
Sean uh if you don't mind would you host
tonight at nine o'clock
hmm
uh would you go to iOS tonight
I think I'll be there tonight at nine I
don't have any other plans tonight all
right it was a trick question
that was a real hard the only thing I'm
missing is I usually get an introduction
for from a marching band
you got Joe by the way what an
incredible story right exactly he's
great he's going to be singing just a
minute all right Mr Hannity thank you
very much
every other Monday you're joining us
right
what's that every other Monday right
you're waking up at this time with us
I'm sorry you guys are yes
we're using a satellite we're losing a
satellite sir I'd love to come on with
you guys you know that uh I think the
world of all of you even Brian thank you
that hurts my feelings last time I know
let me see acknowledge me what about
Carly Carly's back there too I can hear
you oh we love Carly yeah she's great
all right I mean you guys have a great
show I watch every day so all right all
right thanks Sean thank you sir okay I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
aimsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis